I was 36 years old when I was diagnosed
with breast cancer I was new to New York
City I'd lived here for about a year and
a brand new job had only been at at a
very high-end fitness club for about
five months and I was having just really
getting to enjoy the city and enjoying
my new job and I was I felt a lump one
night you know putting lotion on I I
pretty much knew what it meant my sister
was diagnosed at age 32 with breast
cancer so I knew that I had a high risk
being that there was a hereditary option
knowing that that the risk was higher
having a sister with breast cancer I
knew that there was a chance that I
could get it to but it doesn't prepare
you to find out that you've got cancer
yourself they rallied around me and that
was the most important thing I think the
having their support and their love and
knowing that they were there for me and
making sure that I was getting the best
care i think each one you know made
phone calls to find out from their
friends and family they knew of any
breast cancer surgeon or doctor that I
needed to see who are the best so
everybody picked up the phone and
started to call and make you know come
up with names for us to make
appointments with one of my dear friends
Tim said well if it's good news we're
going to get a room at the ribs and
we'll all celebrate and if it's bad news
we're going to the risk and we're going
to have a lot of drinks and so turn out
to be bad news but all my friends
rallied and showed up that night we all
had dinner in a room and we made it into
the sort of private little party and
actually was we did this at the
Peninsula Hotel not the roads we
couldn't get into the ribs so the
potential
hell and it was just a kind of a surreal
evening I think for me the most
important thing was to find out what it
was going to be like instead of waiting
for to happen so whenever I would go to
a doctor's appointment I would ask them
if I could speak to a patient in their
office that could help give me some
information about what it was like for
them and they were going through that
stage of the process so for instance I
wanted to talk to as many women in the
office who had already had their surgery
I wanted to know what it felt like I
ended up having a double mastectomy and
I wanted to know what it was going to
look like after surgery I wanted to see
what it was going to look like with the
once the reconstruction was complete so
I was prepared and I think that helped
me tremendously and I tell most women to
do the same